[Musik]
herzlich willkommen in meiner bude
sebastian deck die miesen tricks der
döner buden auf riecht wie döner
schmeckt wie döner
wir zeigen was wirklich im fladenbrot
steckt sebastian lege schaut sich mal
genauer an was verbraucher da serviert
bekommen
bis jetzt habe ich mich immer um die
produkte aus dem supermarkt gekümmert
heute geht es um die döner aus der
dönerbude dönerfleisch kommt immer
häufiger aus polen in der nähe von
breslau befindet sich eine der
modernsten dönerspieß fabriken der welt
sebastian lege trifft hier den
frankfurter geschäftsmann ercan alten
der kauft seit jahren in polen ein
die fabrik produziert genau das was
dönerbuden in ganz europa brauchen
wahnsinn 40 tonnen am tag von diesen
roboter einiges mit und in die ganze
welt exportiert wir sind hier aber im
größten ölproduzenten der welt
die roboter grillen schneiden und
verpacken das fleisch für supermärkte in
skandinavien und osteuropa
[Musik]
ein paar hallen weiter lässt er john alt
und seine döner spieße für den deutschen
markt produzieren
aus den geschnittenen rindfleisch
hier siehst du wirklich den aufschnitt
auf sebastian kummer wie kann man da
kannst du das durch ko kreis ist
wirklich die kunst letztendlich eines
guten döners dass du die scheiben so
denken wie möglich auf schneiders und
traditioneller döner besteht allein aus
diesem scheiben fleisch doch inzwischen
kommt bei fast allen döner produzenten
zusätzlich sogenannte spread zum einsatz
das besteht aus zerkleinertem fleisch
fett wasser und gewürzen
[Musik]
der trick die fleischmasse ist viel
billiger als echtes scheiben fleisch so
sparen die hersteller bei der teuersten
zutat berlin hat reagiert und die döner
verkehrsordnung erlassen
höchstens 60 prozent fleischmasse sind
erlaubt mindestens 40 prozent scheiben
fleisch sind vorschrift alles andere
darf sich in deutschland nicht mehr
döner nennen
spieße mit anderen rezepturen dürfen
immer noch hergestellt und angeboten
werden
dieses fleisch darf bei uns aber nicht
mehr als dünger verkauft werden
tiefgekühlt werden die spieße von polen
nach ganz europa exportiert nach zwölf
stunden im schock frosta ist so ein
spieß über ein jahr lang haltbar
das ist mal richtig kalt ist aber auch
ganz wichtig bayern so schneller
gefrotzelt wird und so kleiner die
eiskristalle umso besser später das
produkt die fabrik hat auch eine
vollautomatische and bremsanlage für
hühner schenkel aufgebaut
[Musik]
ist das cool dass mit oben angeschnitten
dann wird heruntergezogen durchgedrückt
herausgedreht und fertig vollautomatisch
aber noch nie gesehen mega
alles für hähnchen dönern die in
deutschland immer beliebter werden
allein in dieser halle werden 30 tonnen
hergestellt
pro tag
[Musik]
hähnchen dönern besteht immer zu 100
prozent aus hähnchenfleisch döner aus
kalb rind oder lamm enthält immer einen
anteil fleischmasse
er john alten hat seinen fast food spies
nebenan zum probieren vorbereitet er
serviert döner ganz nach der berliner
döner verkehrs ordnung eine ehrliche
fachmännische meinung dazu ganz so gut
da wie noch nie gegessen weil auch so
frisch
der ist jetzt frische aufgekommen frisch
gegrillt der hat so eine saftigkeit
super richtig lecker sie ist es auch
ganz deutlich die hat vielleicht alle
zehn scheiben fleisch so man hat richtig
bisher ist hackfleisch masse würde man
gar nicht so mitbekommen weil
hackfleisch ist eine feine körnung ist
wie ein schwamm wo man durchbeißt aber
hier haben auch richtig was zu beißen
und das ist in zum brot mit salat
richtig schön wenn man auch merken ist
boehner muss also echtes fleisch
enthalten alles andere ist in
deutschland verboten
[Musik]
doch die dönerspieße viele imbisse sehen
verdächtig gleichmäßig aus steckt da
wirklich echtes fleisch drin halten sich
deutschlands dönerbuden an die regeln
ein test einkauf in düsseldorf soll das
überprüfen
und tatsächlich bei einem der test döner
kann sebastian läge beim besten willen
keine spur von scheiben fleisch erkennen
stattdessen entdeckt er jede menge
winzig kleine helle stellen
dieses fleisch ist offenbar zu 100
prozent eine geformte masse das hier
sieht ein bisschen aus mystery tabelle
und wenn mich hier raus schaue erkenne
ich so kleine weiße pünktchen
hier kann man es aussehen das ist kein
fett wird wäre gar nicht mehr so
deutlich zu erkennen durch die hitze das
paniermehl drin
im labor werden die zehn döner proben
genauer untersucht das ergebnis sechs
hätten so nicht verkauft werden dürfen
mehrere kalb döner enthalten kaum kalt
im besten fall sind weniger als ein
drittel kalbfleisch nachweisbar bei
einem sind es sogar nur 0,4 prozent und
ein lamm döner enthält gar kein lamm
die beamten der lebensmittelaufsicht
kennen das problem seit jahren machen
sie die beobachtung dass kunden
zunehmend spieße serviert bekommen die
die qualitätsanforderung für döner nicht
erfüllen
richtig dünner knapp ist eben teurer als
ballett am spieß und deswegen kaufen
viele imbissbetreiber bulette am spieß
und deklarieren ist eben an ihren
geburtstag nicht richtig das ist kein
kavaliersdelikt in der regel ist man
dann vorbestraft ein guter dünger ist
eine traditionelle grill spezialität was
die industrie in billig spieße mischt
das zeigt sebastian lege
dazu brauche ich folgende zutaten rinder
hackfleisch ein spezieller hergestelltes
paniermehl phosphat stärke eine sehr
intensive gewürzmischung salzwasser und
eis möglichst viel dünner mit möglichst
wenig fleisch herstellen
sebastian lege zeigt den trick er
strickt mit wasser und ganz viel eis das
bringt in fleisch bis maximal profit
wenn die döner messe fertig ist hat sie
maximal 50 prozent fleisch
den rest habe ich für mich gestreckt
paniermehl ist eine weitere beliebte
billig zutat die massenhaft zum einsatz
kommt die döner industrie ist in
deutschland eine der größten paniermehl
verbraucher überhaupt
jetzt machen wir mal unseren dönerspieße
dünner dürfen das gar nicht mehr nennen
dann würde ich sagen dann ist das ein
hackfleisch brot spieß mit
orientalischer gewürzmischung unter
solch wohlklingenden fantasienamen
bringen die döner fabriken ihre billig
spieße auf den markt viele
imbissbetreiber verkaufen die einfach
als dünner
den link jetzt hin
ich muss ihn sowie können so erfahren
wir von vornherein der scheiben
fleischanteil verleiht echten döner
nicht nur geschmack sondern auch
stabilität bei sebastian legis
billiglöhner muss allein die
frischhaltefolie halt geben
doch die mühe lohnt sich denn dieser
billig spies kostet im vergleich zum
echten döner weniger als die hälfte
ich würde sagen das reicht
schnell tiefgefrieren damit der spieß
auch ohne folie seine form behält und
tatsächlich gut gebräunt sieht sogar
sebastian egner noch appetitlich aus
herzige korb in legerer bude dass sie
doch lecker aus ein echter schummel
imbiss mit wenig fleisch und ganz viel
wasser
[Musik]
rang
krieg wieder
schmeckt wie ein döner fabriken
produzieren fleisch am spieß in ganz
unterschiedlicher qualität
sie verkaufen die ware ordentlich
deklariert die boden selbst sind die
schwachstelle
sie nehmen zu oft billig spieße und
verkaufen sie verbotenerweise als
hochwertigen döner
was fehlt sind wirksame kontrollen
doch die zuständigen stellen sind
chronisch überlastet vertraut ihr eurer
dönerbude beim fleisch oder landen
lieber verlassen oder halloumi im
fladenbrot sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniere die zdf
besser esser und schaut in die nächsten
zwei clips